le moment il ya un petit coup de gueule
de raymond et apprend à parler koh lanta
comprenez vous le déferlement de
critiques entre la finale et sur mon
conducteur
regardez ce qui m'a ému at on assisté à
la finale la plus éclatée au sol de
l'histoire de limousines non pas moi je
suis content parce que je pensais qu'on
avait pas le faire parce que le coup de
gueule là que j'ai eu ce week-end j'ai
vu votre copine ophélie winter là à tout
cela qu'il fallait et dépassé oui bon ça
va encore la défendre mais c'est très
bien défendre des larves et à risque
mais dans dans la smart alors vous
l'avez appelé mais ophélie ma chérie je
vais t'aider etc etc
moi je vous le dis et je le répète les
gens comme ça qu'on eut du bonheur dans
leur vie plus qu'il n'en faut et qui se
déglingue tout seul parce qu'ils font de
la merde avec le rend leur argent au
lieu de faire des choses un terrain
intelligent et intéressant de chercher
tout le temps les aider vous appelez que
ce soit même tous les chroniqueurs là
vous avez toutes les deux minutes mon
bébé ma chérie accurso fait un coup
c'est vrai là le reina repoussait à tous
et maintenant ça me faisait un amant
qu'elle un coup c'est bernard montiel
lie jusqu'à la fin la dentelle et
loisirs ce qu'est la sortie vous avez
pas vu de l'article à la sortie tout ça
il ya commente ici qui suit n y vais
regarder
bah moi j'en sais rien à s'arrêter là
sort des trucs comme ça attendez ça se
fait pas ça ah oui mais ça se fera
on se met pas luna c'est le s'acquitte
appelé réfléchi dans ta tête avec tout
ça on n'a pas plus brillé viennent non
mais tu la mets pour prendre des
nouvelles oui c'est simple époque quand
à l'aller mais oui tu dois bon tu va
proposer l'hôtel et que c'est en
acceptant oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
bâtiment vous allez proposer un parmi
eux mêmes des banques cerny et
remerciements qu'est ce que c'est le
remerciement j'irai partout sauf si elle
est là elle a pas tout sauf que et je
veux pas faire le nahd les fonds ne
coupez pas la parole je veux pas faire
de [ __ ] sauf qu'en attendant elle vous
a dégringolé ça c'est pareil non mais la
vierge c'est bien je lui demanderais
bien entière c'est bienvenue à des gens
faux pas les aider et vous allez jouer
des soins de personnes
il a raison faut pas aider des gens
comme ça ils vont travailler décision là
à oui c'est foutu dans la merde tout
seul c'est devenu une épave
il a raison de lui c'est vrai sans
rigoler c'est vrai qu'avant mais là je
suis nul n'est pas donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi on parle d'elle la pauvre il
vaut mieux la laisser dans son coin et
on la retrouvera prochainement
soulagement dit non à chaque titulaire
ce samedi laisse tomber cd céder ses
parts et des épaves
bah oui
la raison
[Applaudissements]
dès le printemps arrive et eux ils ont
eu de la maison je me fera non non c'est
vrai que c'est comme si moi j'ai envie
c'est vrai c'est comme si je joue
non mais ça reste on voit il a raison on
arrête avec ces gens merci dans l'art
est excellent le débat est clos
merci je suis d'accord avec mon raymond
et la prochaine fois je t'ai coûterait
moins cher vous voulez pas me séparer
mais je vais écouter avait écouté mon
chéri c'est fini maintenant je découvre
au fur et à quatre jours de la fin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ophélie winter ne cache pas que ça
passait pas bien m'a pas empêché de
dormir non plus bas mais c'est pas bien
franchement frérot fritter il paraît
qu'elle veut refaire de la télé qu'elle
croit vraiment que le monde l'attend à
l'ailé chéri e
non mais c'est vrai qu'on va manquer une
chaîne qui impute un quelle idée de fou
on va penneteau fait les winter x
déjà bernard montiel a du mal à trouver
du travail alors une ironie du sort
malgré tout c'est qu'elle est allée dans
des émissions qui la méprise profonde
rassurer tant chez ruquier mais on adore
ok mais quand elle va chez quotidien des
gens qui jamais une l'horaire ne
serait-ce que écouter ou à c'est sûr
donc c'est ça qui est absurde en fait
elle devrait aller plutôt vers des
programmes point nommé léon qui l'ont
toujours soutenu pour plutôt des
programmes assez facile alors ni hyper
bobos qui l'ont toujours je vais vous
dire dans le groupe canal
je pense qu'on verra pas sa gueule
pendant longtemps les chérubins